hey pet people
here at the drew barrymore show we are
pet obsessed
so we're taking time to pause for pause
and introduce you to some of your
favorite celebs
favorite furry friends and today we're
getting to know the myth the legend
the cat nacho flay
[Music]
well we are so excited it is over 225
000
followers on instagram are you kidding
me yeah it's crazy
so glad to be here nacho is very very
excited nacho has such
great stage presence is that something
innate in him did you give him notes
bobby
i gave him nothing this is he you know
he's his own man
he's his own cat nacho has an incredible
personality
he always has presents he's you know
he's a pretty handsome cat i think he
kind of knows that so
you know and he's a big guy he's the
biggest domestic breed
and people who are friends of mine who
come over who are like dog
people who have never had a cat before
like you know i never really considered
you know a cat but like you know after
meeting nacho like i feel differently
about cats now he kind of wins over the
dog side of people
and brings them over to the cats he
converts people he's a converter exactly
right
i heard i mean that nacho's taken after
his dad he's a regular
patreoner tell us about it it's one of
those things that's like any pet parent
talks to their pets i mean let's face it
i mean maybe maybe when there's nobody
around but
i always have conversations with nacho
he whispered in my ear one day hey
listen dad like you know
you feed everybody else you know either
in your restaurants or at home or
your cookbooks or your tv shows
basically every single day like what
about us
what about me and stella's assistant and
i was like you know it's actually a
really good idea and then finally i was
just like let's just do this from
scratch
let's start this family business give
nacho sort of my uh you know not
obviously the inspiration but give him
some of my knowledge as a professional
cook
and kind of bring that to cats
everywhere and so we created made by
nacho we've been working on it for a few
years now
and uh created some amazing recipes with
all amazing ingredients
i love that nachos like excuse me dad
can you just i'll take i'll feel this
question
i'm just basically his spokesperson i
speak for it that's just the way it
works
the nachos give you advice on flavors
did he did he kind of chime in oh he
absolutely
you know nacho has a lot of opinions he
either tells me by meowing
or whispering in my ear or basically
just his um
paw up for you know this is good or pour
it down for i don't like
this what else do you nacho like to do
other than create cat food empires
what's like nacho's favorite pastime
he plays a lot with his sister stella i
would say there's about six or seven
races a day
some wrestling matches they actually
like to drink a lot of water
they won't drink water out of a bowl i
have to actually give them
like a glass because they think it's
mine
and they and if i don't put it in the
glass they won't drink it
stella welcome stella oh my god i'm so
glad we're getting a stella appearance
now
it seems like i've seen a lot of
pictures snuggling on social media
they are they are really good friends
you know nachos six stella's two
so she's kind of new to to our household
you know they have a really wonderful
relationship it's a really nice progress
system relationship
but they really love each other i see
nacho perching on your shoulders kind of
like a parrot now is that something you
had to teach him
no it's something he's always done let
me see if i can get him to do it yeah
let's see
if he'll perch on command
let's do it he usually kind of like goes
up on my shoulder checks out the world
he likes being up high all cats like
being really high up and then sometimes
he turns around sometimes he doesn't
sometimes he jumps off
let's see such balance he's such a
multifunctional cat like
dog cat regular cat parrot cat
you don't need any other pets he's very
very graceful
bobby play and nachoplay the zoomies
[Applause]
round
which celebrity would play nacho in a
movie
robert redford oh such a good one
what would be the title of nacho's
memoir the adventures of nacho play
perfect i would have also accepted nacho
average cat
true he's not here okay we can collab on
that if you want if nacho could ask any
celebrity to catch it which celebrity
would he want to end
definitely drew barrymore but she has to
repeat because i think
well i was going gonna say i'm
interrupting the lightning round and i
know that drew was trying to offer up
her cat peach
and make sort of like a cat love
connection but i will say
i do bobby want to introduce nacho to
miranda hobbs
who's also available
[Applause]
[Music]
just on the off chance it doesn't i
don't want to compete with peach
but maybe you know maybe it can just be
a friendship nacho you're getting a lot
of action on me
it's pretty amazing nacho's a hot
commodity listen he's successful he's
handsome
what more he's entrepreneurial he's
driven he's pumped he's got a lot of
food
okay final question is there any
celebrity that nacho wishes would follow
him on instagram
you know who's like an amazing celebrity
that loves cats is kate beckinsale
she loves her cat and we want hate to we
want kate to follow knoxville
well kate if you're watching come pause
for paws with us let's hang out
well you can check out made by nacho at
madebynacho.com we have tons of ways
to uh get your kitty eating some of the
best cat food in the world but made by
nacho
nacho flav all right bobby and nacho say
pause